a warm handshake amid fears of a cold
war like dynamic
China and America trying to repair the
world's most important bilateral
relationship
the challenge well everything from trade
to technology and Taiwan
the world expects that China and the
United States will properly handle the
relationship
this was the preamble to a three-hour
long sit-down president Xi Jinping
opened and pointed
a Statesman should think about and know
where to lead his country he should also
think about and know how to get along
with other countries and The Wider world
it was the first face-to-face encounter
since Joe Biden took office a period of
rising Mutual suspicion
we're going to compete vigorously but
I'm not looking for conflict I'm looking
to manage this competition responsibly
and I want to make sure make sure that
every country abides by the
international rules of the road
scored along that road American anxiety
about China trying to seize its neighbor
Taiwan I absolutely believe there's need
not be a new Cold War
we uh I've met many times with Xi
Jinping
and we were candid and clear with one
another across the board and I do not
think there's any imminent of attempt on
the part of China to invade Taiwan and I
made it clear that our policy in Taiwan
has not changed at all
but on Ukraine China has it's now said
to be highly concerned with officials
claiming Vladimir Putin never told Xi
Jinping about his plans to invade
Joe Biden acknowledged this wasn't a
Kumbaya moment above all else it was
about keeping the peace and cooling the
rhetoric that hasn't been possible in
Ukraine and Russia's actions there will
dominate this Summit but Vladimir Putin
has decided to sit it out
Indonesian officials say the man he sent
in his place Sergey lavrov was taken to
hospital with a heart condition a claim
he mocked from his hotel
for a decade they've been writing that
our president is ill this kind of game
isn't new in politics
Britain's prime minister Rishi sunak is
trying to play The Diplomatic game his
first big test on the world stage
he started over a light dinner with
Canada's Justin Trudeau but he's
promised his next move will be going
hard on Russia Cordelia Sky News Bali
Indonesia